on met en péril tout l'équilibré du
système sans aucune mesure de
financement
c'est des bases qui sont très anxiogène
pour nos concitoyens sur lesquels nous
mêmes députés sommes très inquiets et
donc dans ces conditions là eh bien il
est logique que les discussions se
passent comme elle se passe actuellement
ils ne peuvent pas aboutir
une fois qu'on a un peu des épées si le
nuage de fumée que reste-t-il dans cette
réforme il reste simplement une mesure
qui va faire en sorte que mécaniquement
génération après génération va pousser
contraint de forcer les français à
travailler toujours plus longtemps mais
travailler plus longtemps pour quoi
faire travailler plus longtemps c'est
aggraver le chômage
et puis pour faire plaisir à qui en
réalité ça passe par un débat un passage
en force par des renvois des ordonnances
c'est à dire des décisions du
gouvernement
indépendamment des choix démocratiques
qui peut avoir lieu à l'assemblée
nationale et après trois mois de
d'opposition violentes d'une partie des
français sur ce sujet ça méritait autre
chose ça ne méritait ne pas être
précipité on défend pied à pied des
arguments pour dire que cette retraite
va abîmer la situation des femmes que la
pénibilité ne sera pas pris en compte
bref on revient avec le débat de fond
pour expliquer que cette réforme les
français n'en veulent pas qu'il faut à
référendum et que l'opinion publique est
contre emmanuel maintenant ça fait deux
ans ça fait deux ans qu'on en parle et
on laisse au parlement quinze jours pour
en discuter
donc c'est déjà un premier problème dans
premier sujet deuxièmement je crois que
fondamentalement on a mélangé plusieurs
sujets dans le système des retraites
on aurait dû se concentrer
principalement sur l'équilibré gimenez g
à la survie des régimes et des pensions
et pas sur une espèce de grand
mouvements attrape tout qui met tout le
monde dans la rue parce qu'on traite
tout le monde avec le même